I have a dog I'm a big dog lover and I
love dogs
and so I watched this year's Westminster
Dog Show and thought it was really cool
okay and this is what's cool about it
the American Count Club introduced a
bunch of rookie breeds that have never
competed before breeds I didn't even
know existed
well these dogs are now touring the
talkshow circuit and guess what we got
an exclusive on having them tonight what
you'd like to see these new brave
let's bring them out here first up an
incredible new breed that was developed
right here in Beverly Hills
it is the Gucci handbag terrier let's
get it out here the Gucci genetically
engineered to be a fantastic
it's like he's drunk and being tagging
out of a bar it's amazing what genetic
engineering can do next up a new breed
of dog that you don't want to mess with
it's the pork you pup give it up for the
pork you pop ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
he refuses to go further
[Applause]
[Music]
another new breed the American Kennel
Club has just introduced its the
all-terrain retriever the all-terrain
retriever can move over oh that didn't
work at all all right let's keep moving
that's okay that's all right
keep the dog here we go
[Applause]
really looks no different yeah regular
golden man yeah it's amazing it's
amazing why they would even bother
calling it something else yeah I don't
know what's happening anymore this one's
up to God here's the unique breed ladies
and um in the long bearded chihuahua the
long beard Chihuahua
happy
love that dog and kill bill cause you
gonna say I bet that dogs real good at
coming yeah real good
and finally the result of months of lab
work the West African lion doodle
[Applause]
absolutely fantastic now as you you may
recall from the last segment that we did
involving the the dogs our golden
retriever went AWOL on us like it was a
golden retriever yeah it was not the
all-terrain retriever no I had promised
no I just thought I should tell people I
will show people we worked at rehearsal
I mean worked I mean the golden
retriever actually kind of cooperated
with us right
and clearly then the golden retriever
decided this isn't very funny I'm
getting the hell out of here they are
smarter than that anyway we'll show you
right now from rehearsal this is the
all-terrain
retriever there he is I loved his tail
is still way he's still wagging even as
we're humiliating yeah tails the way you
can also see him looking around and
thinking I'm not gonna yeah yeah